hello my name is Natan and I will tell
you about worst case to expand our case
reductions this is a joint work with a
mirror boot
our motivation is something called the
expander the composition method it's an
algorithmic technique that was used to
achieve many black spots in the recent
years
for example decremental approximate sssp
Computing
approximate Max flow and dynamic minimum
spending history this technique was so
strong that it managed to reduce large
polynomial factors from from what was
the best upper bounds
before I Define what it is I have to
Define your expander graphs
so we say that the graph G is a fixed
expander if for every non-empty cut s
such that the volume of s is less than
or equal the volume of its complements
volume means simply the sum of the
degrees
so for every such card we have that the
number of outgoing edges denoted by E is
at least face fraction of the volume of
s now we can simply look at the picture
it means that the the total number of
edges which are the incident
to us is not uh is not much larger than
the number of outgoing edges
now we refer to this value P of s as the
conduct interface
and the conductance of a graph J is the
minimum conductance of all such sets
now I want to tell you about the
expandable decomposition theorem it says
that for any graph G and a parameter fee
between 0 and 1 we can partition the
vertex set of J into V1 V2 up to BK
such that the induced sub graphs are all
free expanders
these are the Clusters that we see in
the picture
that the total number of edges between
the subgraphs is small is only a 3 times
M times poly log factor which I'm hiding
and we can compute this partition in
something like M over fiscal time
now let's say we want to solve some
graph problem a the expanded the
composition method says that given the
graph G we can decompose J into three
expanders using the expand of
decomposition that we saw
then run some computation and each
expanded GI to obtain the solution for
Di
this is the step where we can actually
gain a speed up because here we can
utilize the properties of expanders and
some process might actually run much
faster on the graph
if it's an expander
and finally you run some computation on
the remaining outer edges which is kind
of small and then combine all the
solutions together to get an answer for
the original graph G
so that is the expander the composition
method
so we investigate the following
intuition but all that says that all
problems are very easy on worst case
graphs as they are on expanders
when I say all problems I mean natural
and fundamental problems
like maximum matching calculate
for cycle detection and more
which we also do not know how if they
even can be solved in linear or near
linear time so these are the interesting
questions that we have in mind and and
the first question that we ask is
whether this intuition is for
now if this intuition is true it means
that it's enough to solve a problem on
expand our graphs and then we also get
the solution for any graph
and that's what makes many people
believe that perhaps the expand of the
composition method
same about the recent results
is the key to resolve all those
remaining open problems and that's the
second question that we come to
investigate
in this paper
so to answer the first question we need
a way to reduce both case instances of
the problem into expanded drugs
we could of course try to apply the
expand of the composition method because
that's what it does but we suggest to
take a step back here and start with a
simple approach
we'll Define something that is called
direct worst case to expander case
reductance this is the most simple form
of a reduction we contain cause it's an
algorithm that's given a graph J that
puts a graphic line such that zip line
is an expander the solution to G can be
easily computed from the solution to B
Prime
and finally the blow up in the number of
vertices and edges in the prime is small
and when I say blow up I mean that's
simply the size of the Prime is about
the size of G up to some polynomial
factors Maybe
when we design such a reduction
ideally we want to obtain a conductance
that is constant and we want the
reduction to one near linear time
the reason why such reductions are
interesting is because if the problem it
makes such a reduction it means that the
worst case instances of the problem are
expander graphs
so first we get a positive answer to the
first question
and secondly it means that the expanded
the composition method is useless
against this problem
because why would we try to apply
expanded decomposition
if we can already assume that the graph
is an expander the expanded the
composition might as well simply return
on the graph itself so we get a negative
answer to the second question
so the first clock of the talk is
dedicated to these triangles reductions
and we have we will start with two
fundamental problems maximum matching
and triangle detection
so the maximum cardinality matching
problem is to find the maximum
functionality set M such that node 2
address in N intersect the best upper
bound is order of M Times Square Root n
obtained by the mechanic algorithm
algorithm actually runs in near linear
time
the second problem is the triangle
detection problem where we want to
detect this decontented triangle or not
the best of bound is all those the
minimum between n to the Omega and N to
the two Omega over Omega plus one
Omega is the exponent in matrix
multiplication algorithms it's at least
two
and again I want to remark that on
random graphs it's actually not very
hard to see and we can solve this
problem in strongly sub quadratic time
the reason why I'm mentioning where I am
mentioning
the results on random graphs is because
perhaps we can also solve these problems
efficiently on pseudo random graphs like
expanders
and then maybe we can also use for
example the expanded the composition
method to obtain a break tool to any bus
so
this approach will actually fail because
we managed to show a direct reduction
direct wasps to expand our case
reductions
let's start
with a with the basic expander
construction this is a construction that
we use
in many of the reductions
and it's a very simple one given the
graph J we want to construct an
expandergraphy plan
we will add an expansion layer U this is
just a bunch of something like n
vertices
and then we're going to add edges in the
following way for every vertex in J
we're going to separate the degree of B
vertices from U that this is a random
process
and add the edges to them
so it's not how to say that the number
of added edges is order of M is simply
the sum of the degrees
and we prove that assuming that the
degree of every vertex is at least let's
say 100 block n
then with high probability the
conductance of B Prime is a constant
I want to note that
we can also deal with graphs well there
are vertices of small degree if the
degree of a Vertex is smaller than 100
Logan
but you just sample 100 login vertices
from you instead of the degree of way
then the blow up might become n log n
the Block in the number of stages
let me just tell you the idea behind the
construction why will this graph be an
expander so I think it's best to think
about random walks let's say at some
point
in time the random walk in this graph is
a on a Vertex V in G then it has a
probability of at least half to escape
to you
and where does it describe to you to
some randomly defined enable
so this works they should mix well and
therefore
uh
the graph is an expander
let me now tell you how we can use this
construction to obtain a reduction for
maximum matching
so first of all we take the graph we had
an expansion area U using the basic
Construction
the problem is that the the MCM of the
Prime might not be fixed
maybe it might differ depending on the
random depending on the randomness
so
to fix that we'll add the twin vertex 0
Prime to every vertex in you to end is
simply a degree one table
and then it's not very hard to say that
the MCM of jig Prime is simply the MCM
of J plus u
because all those new edges we can
assume that they participate in some
Maximum matching and therefore they're
just between G and U do not so then the
rest of the maximum matching is fully
contained in G
and also with high probability the
conductance of this graph is still a
constant because by adding those
neighbors we did not want the expansion
a lot
so we obtain the following com maximum
cardinality matching admitted direct was
case to expanded case reduction so this
problem is as easy on worst case graph
as it depends on expanders
and the expanded the composition method
is useless against this problem don't
get a negative answer to the second
question
what about triangle detection
can we do something similar
so here we're going to assume that the
graph G is type of x
and also that every vertex has the same
number of Neighbors in every part except
its own
we can assume this because we can always
take any graph
and take three copies of the vertices of
G and then add a copy of the edges
between every pair so the number of
triangles in this new graph will be six
times the number of triangles of the
original graph
and we and the reason why we need this
assumption is because the the Stars Cuts
in this graph have the
uh have a very specific form
they must have about the same volume in
every part
meaning that the volume of s
intersection v i instead of the volume
of s
again this is just because every vertex
in s has the same number of Neighbors in
every part
so in the construction is to pick an
arbitrary part let's say V2 and add an
expansion layer only this is adjacent
only to bitcoin we can say that it it
doesn't add any new triangles it's
simply we only added the bipartite graph
and
also the expansion of this graph is good
because again if the cut is expanding in
G we are done and if it's spells in G it
must contain a lot of volume in V2 and
then it expands between V2 and new
so we obtained the following theorem
that says the triangle detection and
meets a direct worst case to expander
case reduction and again we get a
positive answer to the first question
and then a negative answer to the second
question
the next problem that I want to
investigate is the four cycle detection
problem the goal here is to detect
whether G contains the fourth cycle let
me tell you about the complexity of it
so if the graph is students let's say if
m is at least 10 to the 1.5 then
actually the graph must contain the cell
cycle so the problem is Trivial in this
regime but for smaller Ram the best
known up around is all there was m to
the four over three which is the order
of n Square
and there is a very recent lower bound
of M to the 1.1 assuming the hardness of
triangle detection
so I think it's a very intriguing Gap
to try to resolve and maybe we can maybe
hear the expand of the composition
method might help us
so let's see if we can design let's say
a direct to ask us to expand our case
reduction for this problem
we're going to take the graph G and add
an expansion layerio
the problem now is that we might have
added four Cycles if two vertices in G
had a common neighbor and now they also
have a common neighbor in u
and then we then there is a new fall
cycle that did not exist in G
so there is a solution for that for that
just subdivide all those new edges
between G and u
H and now every four cycle in this graph
is fully contained inside the G
but there is a problem with this
approach that the blow up in the number
of vertices is huge
because they have about M edges between
gnu and we added the vertex for every
Edge
so the CRM that we get here is that all
the four cycle admits a direct was gets
to expand our case reduction the blow up
is very large so we don't really get a
definitive answer to to question one
because it is possible that we can solve
a problem on expanders slightly faster
and then let's say on dense graphs and
it will not tell us anything about the
complexity
on the general graph
and again that also doesn't mean
anything about whether they expanded the
competition I thought will help us to
resolve this problem
so that's actually what we're going to
try to do now we will try to attack this
problem
to something called expand out of the
composition-based reductions
these are the reductions that we started
with in the expanded decomposition
method
I just want to know that they have some
shortcomings
uh for one they produce although they do
produce few expanders the value the
conductance fee is limited to someone
over polynomial again
this is because of known limits to
expand on the compositions
so we cannot expect for example to prove
hardness to two expanders or the
conductance is the constant
and also they rely on heavy machinery
that is involved with the expander of
the composition
compared to the previous
reductions that we saw this is less
desirable
anyway we have no choice we did not
manage to show a direct wascus to expand
our case reduction for four cycle so
let's try to use the expander of the
composition
given a graph J
let's decompose Gene to n to the minus
Epsilon expanders where Epsilon is some
sufficiently small constant
I want to note here that the number of
outer edges is about 3 times M and
because m is bounded by n to the 1.5 we
get n to the 1.5 minus Epsilon
now all we have left to do is only check
if there is a fourth cycle that uses an
outer edge
and in the paper we managed to show that
it can actually be done and strongly sub
quadratic time in N to the 2 minus 0.5
Epsilon
so that's the whole reduction
the total running time
is the timing text to decompose the
graph that's the first term
and the time it takes to check if there
is a soft cycle that uses another Edge
that's the second term
for an Epsilon that is less than 0.25 we
obtain astronomy sub-quadratic time
so the theorem that we get for power
cycle is that it doesn't make the worst
case to expand our case reduction
first of all it's to end to the minus
Epsilon expanders
it's not bad a phylon is arbitrarily
small so anybody who can come up say
with an algorithm that serves four cycle
on N to the 0.01 expanders
and it it will also get a similar
results on General graphs
so I I can say that we do get the
positive answer to the first question
but we we do not get the definitive
answer to the second question
let me tell you a little bit about some
results that we have about exponential
time problems we consider the minimum
dominating such problem and the minimum
vertex level problem
the question here is what is the
smallest constant C is such that we can
solve the problem in C to the end time
factors
[Music]
the problem that we face when we design
when we design reductions for such
problems is that we cannot afford an
expansion layer of size n it's too
expensive
so for vertex cover we do manage to use
an expansion layer that has size order
of log n
and for dominating set we do the same
but size Epsilon n where Epsilon is any
constant
in the conductance
of the of the resulting graph is some
poly Epsilon
we also have some interesting Tech about
parameterized complexity of vertex cover
we managed to to also control the size
of the solution it might increase by
only order of Logan
so the hardness here holds even against
parameterized algorithms
let me conclude the talk we
uh we should we showed that many
quarters do admit direct reductions
maximum Community matching Okay click
sacrifice amorphism this part is in the
paper or when the graph is passed a
minimum vertex cover and minimum
dominating set in particular it means
that the worst case instances are
expanded graphs
and they expanded the computation method
is useless against them
so before cycle detection although we do
obtain a reduction to end the minus
Epsilon expanders it uses the expand of
the composition method
so we get some partial results
let's let's conclude with some open
questions first of all
can we improve the reduction for four
cycle
find say a direct reduction to Omega 1
expanders
I think that another interesting problem
is the max cut problem
here I have a feeling I think there is a
good chance that actually this problem
will turn out to be easier on expanded
graphs
and also what about other models of
computation this technique is useful not
only in the sequential model so what
about reductions in Dynamics streaming
distributed or sub-linear models
what about other emotions so the
randomness
so for example can we design reductions
to similar regular graphs or be better
jumbled graphs these are known Notions
of pseudo Randomness in graphs
and finally
Wireless technology offsets to graphs
maybe we can provide such reductions to
the random strings or absolute random
sets of any of other objects of Interest
so thank you for listening